poses the single greatest threat to
America in his new book Tehran rising
this talk hosted by the George C
Marshall Institute in Washington DC is
just over an hour good afternoon
everyone
thank you for joining us this afternoon
my name is Jeff keator I'm the president
of the George Marshall Institute and it
is my pleasure to welcome you all here
today the Marshall Institute's concern
about science and technology as they
relate to public affairs and
particularly the national security of
the United States leads us to often
consider the context and state of the
security environment and the challenges
that lie there in Tehran rising stands
out among the spate of recent books
about Iran it is a concise and forceful
presentation of the evolution of the
Iranian threat it is a critical view of
the u.s. response to that challenge and
an insightful assessment of what can be
done today the author of the volume Ilan
Berman a friend is one of the Rising
Stars of American foreign policy he is a
vice P is the vice president for policy
at the American foreign policy Council a
Washington DC think-tank a noted expert
on regional security of the Middle East
Central Asia and the Russian Federation
he is consulted for the Central
Intelligence Agency in the Pentagon and
is a frequent guest on radio and
television his writings on international
security in American foreign policy have
appeared in the influential publications
as the national interest the
International Herald Tribune the
Financial Times and the Middle East
quarterly among many others he is an
adjunct professor at the National
Defense University a member of the
Committee on the present danger and the
editor of the journal of international
security affairs please join me in
welcoming Ilan Berman
well thank you very much and let me just
start by saying a sincere word of thanks
to Jeff in to the Marshall Institute for
creating this forum and allowing me to
talk a little bit because as Jeff
mentioned my book on Iran is one of
several that are out there at the moment
but it's certainly a topic that is not
being discussed enough and it's not
being discussed with the clarity that it
deserves among all of the popular uproar
over Iran's nuclear program and and
other elements of its foreign policy so
and I think that's actually a very good
place to start I'd begin by saying first
of all that for the record I come to
Iran by way of regional security in the
Middle East and the former Soviet Union
I don't speak Farsi but as part of my
work over the last four years or so
I've spent a lot of time tracking
security trends in Central Asia and
Middle East the Caucasus the Caspian and
over and over the same unmistakable sort
of trends began to appear Iran was
making major inroads whether political
or economic even military among the
countries of the post-soviet space as we
call it an among countries in the Middle
East and the conclusion was unmistakable
that Tehran was indeed rising of
politically strategically and that it
will be a much greater challenge to the
United States as we move forward which
was this was sort of the impetus for me
writing my book so let me start with
with something that I think is really
occupying headlines in a unconstructive
way at the moment and that's the issue
of Iran's nuclear program over the last
two and a half years almost daily we see
reports of new developments in the
Iranian nuclear program new wrinkles in
Iran's nuclear diplomacy with the EU
three and all the signs point to the
fact that Iran is moving quickly towards
a nuclear capability
and I'm of the mind that it's an
offensive nuclear capability one
intended to create at least a breakout
capability to have nuclear warheads
there are a lot of telltale signs of
this for one thing Iran is matching its
investments in nuclear weapons with
investments in ballistic missiles
long-range ballistic missiles capable of
targeting US allies in the Middle East
and also in Eastern Europe and capable
of targeting US forces deployed in the
region Iran is also pursuing both paths
to the nuclear bomb and in doing so very
robustly both lutonium conversion and
uranium enrichment and it is has
followed a pattern of consistent
obfuscation with regard to the
International Atomic Energy Agency there
are sites in Iran that the IAEA does not
have access to there are sites that the
IAEA has arrived at to find them
sanitized there is a pattern of
deception and derailment that smacks
very loudly of a clandestine nuclear
effort politically I think the reasons
for this effort are fairly clear for
better or worse in early 2002 when
President Bush named Iraq Iran and North
Korea as part of an axis of evil
he lumped Iran with two very different
countries Iraq as it turns out did not
have much if at all by way of weapons of
mass destruction North Korea on the
other hand has since October of 2002
carried out a nuclear breakout and in
effect preempted preemption and I think
that is a really enduring lesson that
Iran's ayatollahs have learned they
don't want to be in Iraq they want to be
in North Korea and that's why they've
learned to love the bomb so what's the
fundamental problem here
my assertion is that the fundamental
problem is that the the nuclear clock
the clock that's ticking down to the
time when Iran has an atomic bomb is
taking much faster than the regime
change clock the clock at which we can
expect some sort of grassroots
transformation in Iran and
if Iran goes nuclear all sorts of bad
things follow for one thing we can
expect some measure of a nuclear arms
race in the Middle East a couple of
examples to illustrate that this is
already beginning it's already getting
underway the IAEA recently uncovered
traces of plutonium at Egyptian nuclear
research facilities and Egypt as you
know is has been historically a major
competitor of the Islamic Republic Saudi
Arabia since 2003 has also been revealed
to have a what could in general parlance
be termed a nukes for nukes for oil deal
with the government of pervez musharraf
in Pakistan and this sort of
proliferation whether it's horizontal or
vertical proliferation within the
Iranian regime when they actually expand
and increase their nuclear capabilities
is very troublesome and it should be
expected to set off the sort of
dangerous domino effect in the Middle
East the second thing that we can expect
if Iran goes nuclear is that the Persian
Gulf is going to become much less
hospitable for the United States over
the last four years a number of
countries in the region have signed
bilateral military Accords with Iran
Saudi Arabia has Kuwait has Oman has and
the trend is clear the center of gravity
strategic gravity in the Middle East and
in the Persian Gulf is shifting its
shifting towards Iran and away from the
United States if Iran acquires nuclear
weapons all of this will become much
much worse because those smaller
countries countries that are living in
the shadow of a nuclear Iran are going
to need to create some sort of
accommodation with their menacing
neighbor and we can expect that to have
a direct impact on the quality and the
vibrance of the u.s. Alliance system in
the Persian Gulf
the third element though is I think what
I think the most significant impact will
be of a nuclear Iran and that is a Rhian
trenchant of the current regime in
Tehran since this summer we've seen a
lot of evidence of a conservative
resurgence the election of a hardline
Iranian president for example the
employment of a number of his cabinet
that have
served in positions of authority in the
Iranian regime's clerical army the
positron and this is all rather
disheartening but underneath that facade
there are empirical sociological and
economic facts that suggest that there
is a possibility for change per capita
GDP in Iran currently is at 1977 levels
unemployment according to official
statistics from Iran is between 20 and
25 percent and rising two-thirds of the
Iranian population which is 70 million
is under the age of 30 and they've lived
most if not all of their lives under the
Islamic Republic and they know exactly
what they're missing
Iran is not a hermit Kingdom like North
Korea Iran has access to the outside
world they have sophisticated internet
capabilities sophisticated satellite
capabilities and they know exactly what
they're missing and you can see that in
the types of rhetoric that you hear from
ordinary Iranians that go abroad to
travel or near Iranians that come here
or among the different unofficial and in
fact band blogger sites weblog sites and
internet news sites that are
proliferating out of Iran but if Iran
gets a bomb all of this is going to
become a thing in the past because Iran
will have the ability to repress its
domestic population with impunity the
way China did in 1989 in Tiananmen
Square the model that China followed
there where it was slapped for a time
with economic and diplomatic sanctions
but over time those fell away is
instructive here and I think Iran's
leaders fully expect that a nuclear
capability on the part of their regime
will strengthen them will create
longevity for their regime and as such
don't view it as a bargaining chip to be
fretted away on negotiations with the
Europeans so the operative question now
becomes how far away is Iran from the
bomb and here I think even the US
government is of two minds as recently
as two three weeks ago The Washington
Post reported on a leaked leaked
National Intelligence Estimate from the
CIA
that considerably altered projections of
when Iran's nuclear capability is going
to materialize previously the US
intelligence community had been somewhat
coy and they talked about the fact that
a nuclear Iran is unlikely until later
in the decade the new nie is by
comparison fairly clear they don't think
that a nuclear Iran will materialize
until the middle of the next decade
until 2015
[Music]
frankly this is foolish and it's foolish
because there are many unknown unknowns
that the intelligence community is not
paying enough attention to first of all
Iran is very aggressive on the nuclear
black market in the former Soviet Union
in terms of its acquisition efforts in
fact as long as those as long ago as
1994 elements of the regime were already
attempting to acquire fissile material
or even a complete nuclear warhead from
Russia's crumbling nuclear cities and
the CIA has publicly said that it has
not been able to keep pace with those
sort of acquisition efforts so we don't
know what Iran has and as such we can't
really judge when an offensive weapon
eyes nuclear capability will become a
reality
and by the way all of this is entirely
besides the point because whenever we do
our planning our strategic planning for
having a coherent policy towards Iran we
cannot go by our own internal timelines
we have to go by the timelines of the
most skittish member of our coalition in
that endeavor and that country happens
to be Israel and the Israelis think that
a nuclear capability in Iran is going to
materialize much sooner the most recent
estimates out of Israeli military
military intelligence is by mid 2008
that's quite a ways closer than the 2015
estimate of the National Intelligence
Council and if your if Israel or any
other member of our coalition that sees
the Iranian nuclear threat is more
pressing than we do become seized of the
notion that we are not moving smartly
enough in our strategy to deal with that
sort of timeline they're liable to take
matters into their own hands and
I would posit that that is a fairly
dangerous enterprise so here we get to
what I think is the fundamental question
what can the United States do for the
last half year so the administration has
been pursuing nuclear negotiations by
way of the u3 Great Britain France and
Germany and these negotiations as of
last week have really dead ended but
there are a number a number of false
premises that suggest that even if they
do restart this is not the way to go
first of all the end goals are different
between the US and its allies across the
Atlantic the president of the United
States has said and gone on record as
saying that we cannot live with a
nuclear Iran officials in Europe have
actually in some corners implicitly
endorsed the idea of a nuclear Iran or a
semi nuclear Iran or some semblance of a
nuclear sector in Iran that remains
intact and able to be converted for
military use so clearly there's a
problem here it's a problem of
incompatibility then the second issue is
there is no endgame the International
Atomic Energy Agency which is the main
international organ that monitors
compliance with the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty has no teeth
the only thing that it can do if Iran is
deemed in non-compliance of its
obligations is to refer the matter to
the United Nations Security Council and
here we run into another diplomatic mess
because two of the five permanent
members of the Security Council Russia
and China are also two of the principal
suppliers for the Iranian nuclear
program so we are very likely to face
exactly the same sort of deadlock that
we faced a couple of years ago when you
have entrenched interests in the
Security Council lobbying against full
lustration full disclosure in the
nuclear endeavor in Iran so how do we
influence this and and here I talked a
bit about this in my book let me just
throw out three ways in which we can
begin to cope with Iran's nuclear
ambitions
the first has to do with defenses the
countries in the Persian Gulf
especially the Gulf Cooperation Council
states have been unequivocal in the fact
that they are not comfortable with a
nuclear Iran every time they have a
their annual meeting the issue a
communique that talks about the missile
threat emanating from the eastern side
of the Persian Gulf and if you look at a
map it's quite clear who they're
referring to so the idea that we could
provide defenses to these countries that
would mitigate somewhat against a
potential nuclear blackmail threat
should be very high on the mind of
planners in our defense community
because even the types of deployments
that we're seeing now limited theater
missile defense deployments inject a
sense of ambiguity in a sense of doubt
in Tehran whereas previously there would
be none and four countries in the
Persian Gulf standing not beside Iran
but beside the United States requires
some sort of defense against this
expanding nuclear capability the second
thing that I would suggest is we are not
spending a lot of time thinking about
how defenses can function in the
post-soviet space in Central Asia and
the Caucasus and this is really quite
counterintuitive the idea that we could
base whether on land or on sea defense
is capable of intercepting Iranian
missiles shot from the Iranian mainland
towards Europe or towards Russia has
really not been has not been explored in
the way that it deserves and this is
counterintuitive because right now the
u.s. working through NATO in tandem with
Russia is in the process of building up
the Kazakh Navy
the idea is you create a naval
capability for Kazakhstan and you create
the ability for a sense of regional
stability in what is rapidly emerging as
a very important energy producing region
the idea that that force or even a
different one can function as a hedge
against a potential Iranian aggression
directed towards Europe or Iranian
nuclear blackmail towards Eastern Europe
has not been explored in enough detail
and frankly I think that's a shame
because according to some estimates 90%
of Iranian ballistic missiles fired from
the Iranian mainland towards Europe have
to pass over the Caspian or black sea's
so that makes those bodies of water
ideal places to base defenses if we
don't want that to happen the second
thing that we can do I think has a lot
to do with counter proliferation the
president's probably his most important
and underappreciated international
initiative is something called the
proliferation Security Initiative or psi
and that is not an international
organization it's a series of bilateral
partnerships between the u.s. and
countries like Turkey countries like
Russia that create a new framework for
interdiction of WMD proliferators create
a new framework for intelligence sharing
on weapons of mass destruction this is a
very positive step in fact I think the
proof is in the pudding according to
some estimates we've curtailed the bulk
of North Korean missile trade over the
last two to two-and-a-half years just
using the PSI now Iran is not North
Korea Iran is not as isolated by
geography but psi frankly has not
migrated fully to the Persian Gulf it
has not been the US has not been serious
about engaging countries like countries
in the Gulf Cooperation Council about
the idea that they need to create a
regional initiative that can control
proliferation to and from Iran and I say
from Iran because there's a lot of
evidence to suggest that Iran is
becoming a secondary proliferator the
technologies that end up in Iran are
passed on to countries like Syria until
recently two countries like Libya and
two groups like Hezbollah in Lebanon so
this should be a source of concern and
it should be something we're paying more
attention to and here also there's a
workable model of what this could look
like through a series of bilateral
efforts with countries like Azerbaijan
and Kazakhstan which all go under the
rubric Caspian Guard the US
Defense Department has gone a long way
towards enhancing security in the
post-soviet space by increasing
intelligence capabilities maritime
intelligence capabilities interdiction
capabilities border security
capabilities so there is a model to work
from and it's unfortunate that they're
really not the model is not being in
internationalizing the way that would be
constructive and the third point is is I
think a broader strategic one our
alliance system in the Persian Gulf has
eroded considerably over the past
several years and continues to erode in
spite of the infusion of US forces in
support of Operation Iraqi Freedom and
when I talked a minute ago about
countries like Saudi Arabia Kuwait and
Oman that have had to sign bilateral
military pacts with Iran it is precisely
because of that dynamic they are left to
their own devices and they have to
create some sort of modus vivendi with
their larger neighbor so this doesn't
mean though that those countries are
natural allies of Iran and I think
that's where we fall into a very
dangerous miscalculation
all of them I would say almost without
exception are very worried about Iranian
capabilities and that means that how we
talk to them how we deal with them and
discuss their regional security through
their eyes becomes very important in
preserving the security and stability of
our alliance system in the region we're
already seeing an erosion of that system
and a nuclear Iran or a nearly nuclear
Iran will accelerate that dramatically
but I think it's important to point out
that all of the foregoing everything
that I've just talked about is the first
part of the puzzle
all of this all these initiatives or
potential initiatives are designed to
create a window of opportunity what the
u.s. does with that opening once it's
created depends a great deal on what it
sees as the end goal of American policy
the question really is is the end goal
of American policy regime change or is
it simply behavioral modification
and personally I favor the former
because I think the Iranian regime's
track record its support for terrorism
its meddling in countries like Lebanon
countries like Iraq suggest that that
type of hostility that type of
expansionist ideology simply too
ingrained to be modulated without any
sort of structural change to the regime
but that's just my opinion this is the
fundamental question facing the
administration and so far the White
House has failed to articulate a clear
vision for what it wants Iran to look
like in five years in ten years and I
think that's a crucial point because it
has to do so in five years or ten years
depending on who you believe Iran will
be nuclear and whether that nuclear Iran
is a threat to the United States it
depends entirely on whether the regime
that's in power and Tehran still
considers itself to be at war with the
United States in the West the current
regime does a post theocratic one might
not and that is the opening to a
discussion about how to look at regime
alternatives how to look at empowering
opposition groups and it's a discussion
that the administration needs to have
and it needs to have in short order so
let me stop there I'll be glad to
entertain any questions that you have
Peter
I think I know what you were saying but
just so that it's clear because some
others might take longer you're not
saying that the administration's
inclusion of Iran with North Korea and
Iraq
if they hadn't said that that a Rams
nuclear path would have been different
no I think what the only thing you did
is that it crystallized some of the
thinking into Iran and accelerated their
interests in getting a nuclear weapon
there any a nuclear project actually is
older than the Islamic Republic itself
it started in the late 60s early 70s and
it included a national ambitious plan
for civilian nuclear energy actually
more ambitious than the plan that the
current regime is pursuing but a lot of
whether or not we thought it was a
threat emanated from the character of
the regime the Shah was despite his
deficiencies a reasonably pro-western
reasonably pluralistic and we did not
think that he constituted a threat to
the United States by contrast the
current regime does and that I think
makes all the difference sir this idea
what Israeli preemption might look like
would it be would they have to go in
order to do that would certainly air
strikes what are they thinking well and
I think that's that's a very important
question because even the Israelis say
publicly that this is not a good idea it
doesn't mean they're not going to do it
they just think it's not a good idea and
Israel has limited options because for a
number of reasons first of all the paths
the pathways that it could take to get
to Iran are limited there are really
only three ways they're straight across
to the eastern side of the Middle East
through Jordan and Iraq there's north
through Turkey and there's south through
Saudi Arabia and the O Soraka campaign
in 81 was conducted south through Saudi
Arabia and the Saudis have learned from
this
so the Saudi route B has become much
more problematic for a number of reasons
I suspect that the new Iraqi government
would be less than excited to have
Israeli warplanes over flying its
territory and that leaves Turkey and in
the past
as a result of the strategic partnership
that Jerusalem and Ankara built over the
last decade the Israelis could consider
reasonably prudently begin to talk about
the idea that the Turkish Israeli
strategic partnership could be oriented
against Iran I don't think that's the
case any longer you've seen a number of
strategic shifts in Turkey that have
really modulated Turkey's approach
toward Iran have put them on an
accommodation it stands rather than a
confrontational one and this makes this
takes turkey off the table for all
intents and purposes as a partner in
this now the question becomes one really
of capabilities and of political
timelines the Israelis have spent a lot
of time diversifying their strategic
arsenal they are working very hard on
advanced missile defenses like the arrow
theater missile defense system they are
working on additional systems and there
they've taken their a strategic
deterrent offshore because Israel is a
one bomb country and if a nuclear
warhead of enough yield is shot at
Israel Israel ceases to exist unless it
has a credible second strike capability
and that means that the Israelis have
put priority investment on weapons like
dolphin client submarines that are
nuclear capable that can take their
presumed nuclear option offshore and
create the ability to have survivability
in terms of retaliation and really here
I think a quite there's a question of
that's all defense when you're talking
about offense there's a lot of question
marks about the capability of Israeli of
the Israeli Air Force to go from here to
there to really deal with the Iranian
nuclear program and it's useful to
remember that Iran has learned the
lesson of the O's Iraq campaign and 81
very well they've separated their sites
they've hardened them they put them
underground so now even Israelis that
talk about the idea of preemption
realize that this is probably not a good
idea and it's not going to deal with the
Iranian nuclear threat cave
comprehensively what they do say though
and that's why they spend a lot of time
emphasizing the idea that this is the
world's problem this is an Israel's
problem you should think about our
timeline and they've been you know
fairly good at doing
but none of this means that the Israelis
aren't going to do anything they might
if they think a red line has been
crossed and even if they think a red
line has been crossed and nobody else
thinks a red line has been crossed they
do not have the luxury of being
separated from Iran by a vast ocean so
their threat perceptions tend to be a
little bit more acute than ours and that
has to be I think in all prudence
calculated into our considerations any
time we're doing strategic planning sir
with oil prices reaching $70 can the
policy of economic incentives work and
more importantly can sanctions work in
this order maybe and probably not the
real secret of the war on terror the
sort of the unsavory fact of the war on
terror is that Iran as well as countries
like Saudi Arabia who are major energy
producers major producers of world
patrolling are actually getting stronger
and not weaker Iran's federal budget
that we know about the Department of
Energy knows about for 2004-2005
projects the federal budget to be one
hundred and twenty seven billion dollars
half of that money comes from oil
revenues and oil revenues pegged to a
per barrel price of $19.90 so you don't
have to be a mathematician to realize
that Iran is netting dozens of extra
unexpected billions of dollars and one
only hopes that they invested in social
services or education but I suspect what
we're going to see coming down the pike
is a quantitative and qualitative leap
in the sophistication of their offensive
technology the sophistication and
capability of their nuclear program and
that's going to reverberate very I think
very ominously unfortunately we don't
have a lot of strings that we can pull
we in fact when it comes to sanctions
have much less pull than our allies
across the Atlantic for example we as a
result of legislation passed over the
last decade have divested ourselves or
disincentivized
us-based multi
Nationals for invent from investing in
companies relating or assets relating to
Iran so in terms of us having economic
levers were not in a very good position
and this requires I think a discussion
of whether or not a transatlantic
approach can really be established
because I think there is a utility for
Europe in all of this certainly on the
economic front
it requires though a more proximate
estimation of the Iranian nuclear threat
between Washington and its allies
Sir William boys China I mean many of
argue the China's greatly increased over
the past three or four years economic
investment in Iran is greatly limited
our options against Tehran one the
Security Council seems more and more
iffy and secondly sanctions are much
more if and I like you to talk more
about how the China card has limited us
options absolutely no and I think that's
exactly right I think those estimates
are exactly right because what Iran has
done for itself in effect over the last
year is it has bought itself a Security
Council veto over the last eight months
or so nine months now Iran has signed
two major energy exploration deals with
China worth depending on the estimate
worth either seventy billion dollars
over 25 years or 100 billion dollars
over 25 years that is not chump change
and it is not some change for a country
that's rapidly expanding its economic
base and needs fuel to grow so we have a
problem we have a problem because China
is disincentivized from actually taking
a hard stance towards Iranian violations
of the NPT towards Iranian intransigence
on IAEA inspections and that stance is
only going to get harder as new
resources come online as China a Chinese
industry begins to reap the benefits of
energy partnership with Iran
so I think this is a huge problem and
while I think I take a somewhat
modulated view on
the ability of the Russian government to
really do an about-face and to realize
the risks involved in continuing
partnership I think China is another
matter entirely and I think more than
anything else China is the major
impediment in the Security Council sir
talking about the military option and it
seems to be what you're getting at
people generally don't seem to
understand the social and political
consequences throughout the region of
what this would mean whether it be the
US or probably more so for the Israelis
that the nation itself has seemed to
come together around this demand that
they should have the full nuclear cycle
even those who are opposed to the
mullahs now if this if their attack were
launched even limited attack against
nuclear sites
when this lead to a consolidation of the
nation in a war against the infidel
secondly what would be the effects in
the region you have the Shia who still
look to Iran as a holy place what
happens in Iran what happens in other
regions where the Shia are now rather
calm and peaceful when an attack occurs
which seems to be attack against the
Shia nation aren't those really
incalculable consequences that we would
somehow have to take into consideration
before launching oh absolutely they are
and I'm glad you asked the question
because it gives me an opportunity to
clarify a little bit under no
circumstances do I think preemption is
anything other than a last resort the
types of military strikes that we're
talking about I think the social and
political costs are frankly far too high
as you said the Iranian population they
may be for the regime or against the
regime but they kind of want nuclear
weapons not all of them but a majority
of it and they want it because frankly
they live in a dangerous neighborhood to
the north Russia has them to the west
Israel has them to the east Pakistan and
India have them and by the way when
Pakistan detonated its did its first
initial nuclear test in 98 it did so 30
kilometers outside of the Iranian border
it didn't do it proximate to India I did
approximate to Iran so there's a lot of
evidence to suggest that you know this
is in fact true Iran there's reasons for
the Iranians to want the
and I think what we need to factor in is
subcontracting strategy whether it's to
the Israelis or to the Europeans is not
a strategy and this is a trap that we've
really I think fallen into because this
is hard this is a really difficult and
thorny problem that we're dealing with
but I think you're right the the types
of effects that you would see regionally
and and within Iran where you would have
this idea of rallying around the flag
that would really reinvigorate and
rejuvenate the regime would be precisely
the opposite of the ones intended now
none of this is to say that the Israelis
might not try it or frankly the United
States military for lack of a better
option might not try it they might but I
don't think that's likely and I don't
think it's likely for precisely the
reasons that I mentioned so first I
would like to compliment you on the
emphasis of defensive capabilities it's
something that I've really missed and
seems to be absent and the ballistic
missile defense office also seems to
invest it in the wrong place in the
wrong technology I mean with the
successful Agis intercept five out of
six there should be a massive deployment
of these capabilities throughout the
Middle East and around Korea and I don't
understand you know what's going on and
you should be complimented on it now
after that and disagreeing with your
fundamental analysis on the nuclear
program and Iran
you just agree that the military option
is not credible and one shouldn't even
say it's an option if the option is not
credible it's a mistake I mean you
should only threaten or imply if it's
credible because if you do something
that's not credible you lose credibility
having grown up in game theory I like
mixed strategies and mixed strategies
would be since Iran is an essential
much more compliance of the NPT than say
the United States is is the letter of
the law why not do what we might have
done in Iraq already is take it at face
value so you want to obey the NPT great
you have signed the Additional Protocol
great we now the United States as a
matter of good faith say and we believe
what you said on face value we deploy
the defensive capabilities because we
need the passive capabilities but at the
same time we say look we agree with it
you are entitled by entity to civilian
nuclear technologies you are entitled to
the full enrichment cycle it's all there
it's it's that's what it however since
we don't have have problems you will
agree to a very very tough inspection
regime and here one or two or three
additional paragraphs you have to agree
to for this to go forward this way I
think you actually can bring about
regime change that you advocate because
as long as you oppose the civilian
capabilities that by law and treaty they
are entitled to
you are just reinforcing the young
generation behind the regime that exists
and I think that's the basic flaw and
last point I don't think Iran is
supporting terrorism in Iraq or
Afghanistan
I believe it's correct to say they have
been very helpful in Afghanistan to the
United States and I think also in in
Iraq they don't support so many
terrorists you know that's it just
doesn't make sense I'm not talking about
analyst in Israel but I think in Iraq
and you and Afghanistan it's a wrong
statement again you lose credibility the
basic part it's very important and
shouldn't we probably mixed strategy to
be credible well I think we should and
first of all thank you for for the
compliments before the detractions I I
happen to think that you're right I
think a mixed strategy would work and
the real problem that I see is that
there's not much
of credible carrots or frankly credible
sticks to go around as you said the
military preemption option is not
credible but I tend to disagree it is an
option it's an option simply because
government officials have said it's an
option and it's a mistake to discount
any such statement the president said
we're not going to go to war with Iran
but having said that no options off is
off the table I happen to take the
president's word and it might not be a
good option but it's certainly not
written off the books as it were at the
Pentagon I think and I think that's a
crucial distinction because there have
been plenty in the course of American
history plenty of not ideal options or
even poor options that have found their
way into strategic thinking and with
regard to the Iranian nuclear program
I'm a lawyer although I don't usually
tell people that it gets me disinvited
from cocktail parties all the time but
but I think the emphasis on process is
incorrect for the simple reason that the
MPT is old the NPT is 1968 of 1968
vintage its pre 9/11 its pre war on
terror the emphasis that this
administration takes and you know it's
no secret this administration is not a
big fan of arms control we know this but
particularly over the last four years
the emphasis of the administration takes
is much more about the potential nexus
between WMD and terrorism than it is
about strict compliance with a piece of
paper and that is not me talking that's
just me observing the the facts your
point about the civilian nuclear program
I think is valid in a pre 911 context I
think the threshold for uncertainty on
these things after September 11 and
particularly as US forces are emplaced
on either side of Iran is lowered
considerably to a point where the NPT is
no longer the lingua franca that the
administration is speaking and your last
point about terrorism it frankly I would
have to disagree
you can certainly in the Middle East
there's a plurality of opinion about
what constitute terrorism al Qaeda
people generally agree is a terrorist or
sation many people though in the eastern
Mediterranean don't think that Hezbollah
in Lebanon is or that Hamas is I don't
think those distinctions track very
closely with what my frame of reference
is my frame of reference is the foreign
terrorist organizations list that's
issued by the State Department and it
lists all of those groups as terrorist
organizations and when you do your when
you test the barometer pre 911 and post
9-11 the president has said and again I
take him at his word that you're either
with us or you're with the terrorists
now this has all sorts of shades of grey
when it comes to problematic countries
including Saudi Arabia and Pakistan but
on the aggregate I think it's useful
when you're approaching a country and
trying to figure out whether it's a
threat or an ally to see we're on that
spectrum they fall and if you look at
the type of assistance that Iran is
giving to the Palestinian Islamic Jihad
to Hezbollah
and even the safe harbor that Iran is
giving to al-qaeda and elements of Ansar
al-islam for example the type of
assistance and aid and comfort is
definitely in the latter category
it's definitely assisting international
instability it's not a net positive for
regional security sir talk to me is it
possible that regardless of the regime
in Iran that it will seek a nuclear
capability due to contemporary
realpolitik and its security needs as
well as a result of its historical
experience for example Russia and
Britain in the early 20th century
carving into spheres of influence oh
absolutely I think that the those people
that think that a denuclearized Iran is
a possibility are living on a cloud I
think the Iranian nuclear program is
simply too far advanced to be rolled
back wholesale and not only that but
that sort sort of effort is not going to
meet with support from the Iranian
population even if they're against the
regime so we have to come to grips with
the fact that a nuclear Iran at some
point two years from now three years
from now ten years from now is going to
be a reality and that precisely that
calculation is what makes the discussion
of regime character so important
because let me borrow a phrase from the
NRA it's not guns that kill people it's
people that kill people and I know
everybody laughs but I think that's that
there's actually more than a little bit
of truth to that the type of weapons
that Iran is pursuing the type of
capabilities that Iran is pursuing are a
threat to regional peace and security if
you have a post theocratic reasonably
pluralistic government in Iran and by
the way not one created by forceful
military change from the outside because
I frankly don't think that's in the
offing but one that's created by really
transformative grassroots change those
weapons would become much less dangerous
on a regional scale and Iran would be
much more likely to be viewed as a
mature nuclear possessor than it is
under the current regime
sir.you remarks character has three
initiatives that you recommended the
United States should be undertaking in
order to mitigate the threat being posed
I wonder if you've had discussions with
people from the administration and what
they say when when you make those
proposals you point out they're not
doing these things what do they say
there what is their explanation as to
why they're not implementing the
recommendations well that's my favorite
question so far I have to say because
that presupposes that I'm right which I
always like that's a good question and
the problem is that in the past at least
over the last eight years or so one
official Washington really hasn't known
what to think the election of Mohammad
Khatami who was a reasonably reformist
on their political spectrum cleric as
the president in 1997 really polarized
two camps in Washington a camp that
believed that you could do business with
the President as opposed to the
unelected supreme leader that actually
controls a vast majority of military
strategy for example and a camp that
believes that the type of transformation
that we're looking for will not come
from within the regime at all it will
come from the Iranian people who are
two-thirds of them under the age of 30
etc etc I happen to fall in the latter
camp as you can probably imagine but
that debate has been very illustrative
because it's actually managed
administration policy deadlocked for the
last eight years and not much has
changed there's really an awful lot of
ambiguity about what to do with Iran
what element of the Iranian threat and
and in my book I posit that the Iranian
threat is actually much broader than
just the nuclear question it has to do
with support for terrorist organizations
has to do with what they're doing in the
Persian Gulf and why they're doing it
what they're doing in Iraq for example
the administration has tended to take
depending on your perspective on that
debate rather different positions but
the aggregate result has been that
there's just a lot of inaction and the
problem here is that the nuclear clock
is now ticking very quickly and very
loudly and it is high time for the
United States and the US government to
actually become serious about this sort
of question it's we don't longer have
the luxury of long lead times I think a
great administration official once said
to do this sort of thing and when we
begin to talk about what our strategy
should be those types of personnel
issues become very important the
administration does not have in my
estimation a really coherent strategy
towards what it wants Iran to look like
it's very easy to say you support Iran's
urge for democracy it's another thing
entirely to do things that prove it you
discussed quite thoroughly the process
by which Iran might go nuclear this
issue of matching nuclear investment
with a ballistic missile investment into
the pursuing both uranium enrichment and
in reprocessing the level of their
activity I'm wondering at what what kind
of points what kind of signals would
they send to the international community
would they go forward with a testing
program or what they not would that be
clandestine would they announce
themselves as a nuclear weapons state of
what they not will they go forward and
deploy deploy ballistic missiles with
nuclear capability in the absence of
those two measures how would they go
about the process of doing it what do we
know about that no I think it's an
excellent question and I talked a little
bit earlier about timelines and about
you know factors that go into gauging
your timeline I happen to have a third
separate gauge my gauge is the pace of
the ballistic missile program in Iran
because given the uncertainty with their
nuclear development as soon as Iran can
credibly reach a certain point with a
delivery system you have to assume that
that place or that sphere will be hit by
a nuclear capable missile that's just
prudence dictates that and Iran's the
premier missile in Iran strategic
arsenal the shahab-3 already has a
publicly acknowledged distance of 2,000
kilometers which means that parts of
Turkey all of Israel and even parts of
India are within range they've actually
spent a lot of money on investing and
upgrading that the distance and the
accuracy of that missile they're now
introducing solid motor engines solid
fuel engines for the shahab-3 and
they're trying to increase the accuracy
the projected estimation is that over
the next couple of years the shahab-3
will have a 4,000 kilometer range which
would mean that at least half of Europe
will fall under Iran's nuclear threat by
default and this I think is a really
important benchmark we tend to talk
about the nuclear program in isolation
with the other strategic programs that
Iran is pursuing but more than anything
else the degree to which Iran is
matching investments in nuclear
development with investments in delivery
systems belies a
very substantial intention on their part
if you are pursuing a civilian energy
program and I actually have other
reasons to believe that they're not all
talked about in a second but if you're
pursuing civilian energy program you
will not be closely linking your
ballistic missile program with a
civilian energy program you simply won't
do it it's not prudent it's also not for
him to allocate that much that much
resources to have one keep pace with the
other the other reason and it should
probably should have mentioned this
earlier that I don't think that Iran is
pursuing a civilian nuclear energy
program is because we know that Iran is
a substantial oil exporter almost four
million barrels a day and it is a major
part of opening and we know how much
money it's gleaning as a result of
political instability associated with
the war on terror so the question is why
can't they use their oil but that's
actually I don't think a good question
because everybody can say well they want
to diversify what the real benchmark I
think for me is is that Iran exports
almost four million barrels of oil a day
and yet imports almost 1 billion barrels
of refined gasoline annually and this
suggests that they have a big lag
between what they export and the
refining capability if they were
actually interested in sustainable
energy for their population they would
spend the money not on nuclear reactors
but on refineries and refineries as we
know are much cheaper and if they did
that you could actually make a credible
case that you know this is not enough
but the shortfall that you see in the
gasoline production in the availability
of gasoline in Iran suggests that the
oil is seen not as a net benefit for the
population but as a strategic commodity
to be bartered for other benefits like
money that can be used in the nuclear
program we know that before the 1991
Gulf War that the Iraqi nuclear program
was very extensive there were tens of
thousands of nuclear
missions scientists and engineers level
of effort was incredibly high in the
billions close to ten billion dollar
program what do we know about the level
of effort of the Iranian program and to
what extent are they getting for
technical support by now the Iranian
nuclear effort is not really Iranian
it's really an international affair if
you go to Tehran and I've colleagues of
mine who were there recently they say
you know Georgian Russian Ukrainian
they're ubiquitous on the streets
depending on whether or not you're
proximate to nuclear facilities it's
because there's a lot of scientists from
the former Soviet Union that have been
exported or have exported themselves as
part of that brain-drain process that we
experienced over the last decade in
which they sought greener pastures
perhaps the military programs that they
were working on in the Soviet Union have
dried up financially perhaps they've
been decommissioned and now these people
who have marketable skills that people
pay very handsomely for are looking for
greener pastures and overwhelmingly
they're looking for greener pastures
either on the Korean Peninsula or in the
Middle East and you know as a sign of
this and this is according to Russian
Press reports BuChE air which is the the
public face of the Iranian nuclear
program has been a turnkey Russian
operation operated by Russian engineers
and Russian and overseen by Russian
scientists since at least 1999 and this
suggests that any type of discussion
that we have over the Iranian nuclear
program has more than a little bit a
tinge of how are we going to deal with
Ukrainian scientists how we're going to
deal with the Russians how we're going
to deal with the Georgians and that I
think is a very important point so I'd
like to get back to the Asian aspect of
this I brought up China but it seems to
me that much of what's coming out of
Washington is very Eurocentric very
American Century I have talked about
China but in addition when talk about
our allies India Pakistan Japan is all
fear greatly dependent and
growing more and more dependent on
Iranian energy resources particularly
now the natural gas for India Pakistan
is becoming a major issue this is trying
very hard to dissuade India but it's not
clear whether it will succeed because
tomorrow I believe the Indian Foreign
Minister arrives in Tehran and
everybody's waiting to see what happens
so it seems to me that we have to be a
little careful and not act no totally
alone on this because more and more the
whole Middle East is turning East then
we're playing as if it's our own
backyard where as our allies who sort of
in a bind
particularly the Japanese over the years
who in the u.s. is every year look the
other way when the Japanese have broken
the sanctions made humongous deals with
Iran because we know there's no other
place they can get their energy so how
is this rise of Asia going to affect
their policy toward Iran nuclear program
well it's certainly not going to be
beneficial in the sense that we can rely
on those countries to create a coalition
that is committed to containment and
frankly I actually don't think it's just
Asia I think there's a lot of countries
that are really coming into their own
that are beginning to look at Iran as a
potential quick fix for their energy
problems a good example is Ukraine and
Ukraine is in discussions with the
Iranians in fact this month there's lady
to have discussions over a potential
pipeline that would bring Iranian
natural gas through Ukraine into
European markets and I don't think this
is done because the Yushchenko
government is reflexively anti-american
they're not what I think is that they
have a problem overwhelmingly Ukraine
depends on Russia on Russian energy for
power for electricity and they are
trying to decrease that dependence and
more power to them for doing so but as a
result of this Ukraine and by extension
other allies like India run the risk of
as a result of poor communication from
the
United States because we really haven't
telegraphed our intentions very well
they run the risk of falling on the
wrong side of this looming challenge
that we see coming down the pike and
that has all sorts of implications for
the long term Indian American
relationship the long term Ukrainian
American relationship because frankly
all of these countries need to be told
they have to decide which side they're
going to be on because you can't really
contain Iran without Indian assistance
you can't really contain Iran without
some sort of independent energy forward
thinking energy policy in the Cask me
for example all of those things
unfortunately are still embryonic at
best but in the interim we need to
Telegraph to these countries that those
sort of choices are not cost-free
unfortunately I don't think we are I
don't think we are and that is the
biggest loser of those types of gaps in
public diplomacy will end up being the
United States itself because quite
rightly the Ukrainians or the Georgians
or the Indians will tell you here are
economic realities we need to expand and
diversify our energy sources what do you
suggest and unless the United States has
a forward-thinking plan for Caspian
Development for South Asian development
that doesn't involve Iran but still gets
India what it needs gets Ukraine what it
needs then it is liable to be left in
the dust
ignatius reported a few days ago about a
visit by Shiite high-ranking Shiite the
mullah to the Pentagon Security Council
near and highlighted the possibility of
a naja Washington Alliance and given the
history of Iran
also Israel and I mean just mention
Michael the Dean Richard Perle of global
afar the president of Israel is Iranian
the defense minister
I think is Iranian are you not limiting
your thinking here and isn't the choice
is it a false choice to say you know us
against the terror and what about the
mixed strategy and you know are you
limiting your vision and is that not
actually hurting the United States and
do we have the budget to satisfy all
these people should we not seriously
think of making an alliance with Nadja
they have been very helpful in
Afghanistan to us have been very helpful
in Iraq to the United States they are
anti al-qaeda long before the United
States in fact we created al-qaeda if
I'm not mistaken we sent bin Laden to
their wheel and financed the CIA had we
done some mistakes and should we be more
flexible instead of painting the devil
on the wall say look you are not
entitled to nuclear weapons agree - it's
tough inspection regime like we could
have done in in Iraq and Fukuyama
it's another article which just appeared
it seems also to go along the line so
I've been on some serious questions
beyond the dichotomies that you raise
well there are the one thing I would say
I really would prefer not to get into
the us-israel discussion for a number of
reasons but I would say this that
whenever we're thinking about American
strategy or potential Israeli strategy
towards Iran it's always useful to link
the two because in many ways they're
similar they've been similar in the past
I would hesitate against saying that one
drives the other or vice versa we went
to war with Iraq and Britain supported
us we didn't go to war because Britain
thought Iraq was a threat and I think
that logical logic chain that you do and
could end you up in some very
interesting corner certainly but first
of all this is not a u.s. is
really initiative there's lots of
countries around the world that are very
nervous over Iran and over Iran's rising
power and in fact in my book I talked
about I talked very little about Israel
I talked a lot about for example Russia
or Turkey because I think that those
countries that if you proceed from the
notion that Europe does not have a very
good idea about what it wants to do with
Iran because I don't think they do they
do in fact the current nuclear diplomacy
looks an awful lot like what they tried
during the 1990s that was called
critical dialogue and it backfired
gloriously all it did was give Iran's
ayatollahs money for weapon systems for
terrorism so the point is we need to
look to new allies and here I think
Russia more than anything else is
emerging as a potential wildcard more
and more you're seeing a harder stance
on the part of the Kremlin from with
regard to Iran Iran's nuclear ambitions
there was recently an interview in a
Russian daily with one of the leading
experts on the Middle East from the
quasi-official mokemo which is the
Moscow State Institute for international
relations and he talked about the fact
that later this year Russia will assume
the chairmanship of the g8 and Iran runs
the risk of actually bifurcating the g8
because if it can keep Russia aligned to
its side then the rest of Europe will
not go along with an independent
strategy towards running will not go
along with the United States so his
point the this political scientist point
was there are choices coming down the
pike not only for Washington but for
Moscow as well and when you add in the
fact that more and more the idea that
the Russians had during the 1990s that
proliferation to the third world was
really a cost-free initiative don't
really hold water anymore there are some
estimates at a Moscow now that by next
year 20 million ethnic Russians in the
south of Russia parts of Kazakhstan and
parts of Ukraine will be under ballistic
missile range from Iran that's a pretty
significant constituency for Vladimir
Putin and I think that the more facts
like this and the more assessments like
this begin to leak out the more you're
going to see a modulation of stance on
the part of the Kremlin what we need to
do is we need to be ready to seize the
moment and over the last decade we spent
a lot of time haggling with the Russians
please don't build the Bushehr reactor
it's 800 million dollars we'll give you
800 million dollars instead that kind of
misses the whole point until now
Russia has seen Iran as a hedge against
perceived American hegemony in the
Middle East it's a very useful tool and
proxy for them
I think that's beginning to change and
our discussions with the Russians should
change along with it
ethically say the White House called and
you had a few minutes with the president
what would you tell him he needs to
start thinking about piece of ear well
after I got my stammering out of the way
I would say that that really I mean it's
this two-tier approach that in my
opinion holds the most the most
potential if Iran goes nuclear tomorrow
all of this discussion is besides the
point because all the things that I have
said really flow from it new potential
nuclear arms race less hospitable
Persian Gulf etc etc so the idea is you
have to keep the window of opportunity
open as long as possible but that's the
easy part I know it doesn't sound easy
but that's the easy part
and once we have that window of
opportunity once we've delayed the
Iranian nuclear program because it's
quite clear that we can the Israelis
used to talk about late 2004 as what
they call the point of no return for the
program when they have all the
indigenous capabilities necessary to
build a nuclear weapon
now these rails are talking about 2007
or late 2006 so it's quite clear that
you can flex their timeline what you
can't do is you can't change the
endpoint Iranians whether they're for
the regime or against the regime want
nuclear weapons and want to be a nuclear
power in its own right and want to see
that that great power table so the
question becomes when they do get a seat
at the table because I'm firmly
convinced that they will how do you
structure your outreach so that they the
regime that ultimately takes possession
of those weapons weapons is a mature one
it's not a threat to the United States
and is reasonably pluralistic and that I
think is we haven't talked much about
that but that I think is a number of
initiatives in and of themselves for
example the types of outreach we were
doing to the Soviet Union during the
Cold War are markedly absent today both
with regard to Iran and frankly the rest
of the Middle East
I I did a little bit of number crunching
in part of my research for my book and
found out that or at least the numbers
that I was given was that public
broadcasting towards Iran through the
broadcasting Board of Governors for 2005
was estimated initially at sixteen point
four million dollars and that includes a
rate both radio and television there are
70 million Iranians living in Iran and
so again not a mathematician but roughly
translated out that's slightly less than
22 cents per Iranian per year you can
argue about how much we should increase
that certainly but I frankly think that
by any yardstick this is probably a
small price and it should be increased
it's less than a third of what we were
paying per Soviet in 1983 so we have a
ways to go in terms of our public
outreach but we also need to have a
coherent vision of what we want our on
to look like and frankly time is running
short for us to articulate that vision
and to empower a forces both within Iran
and outside of Iran that can actually
make that vision a reality
pleasure copies of T around rising are
available for purchase out in the
hallway and Ilan has agreed to stay
around and sign copies of the book and
answer your other questions that you may
have please join me in thanking him for
the insightful presentation
[Applause]
ahman vermin is vice president for
policy at the American foreign policy
council and adjunct professor of
international law and global security at
the National Defense University in
Washington DC Tehran Rising is published
by rowman & littlefield on the web at
Roman littlefield calm